ich liebe es einfach abends lecker essen
zu gehen danach noch die ein oder andere
Bar zu besuchen und den Abend eventuell
in einem tollen Club ausklingen zu
lassen leider gibt es in großen Städten
und an touristischen Orten auch jede
Menge dieser Lokalitäten mit unfassbar
schlechten Bewertungen ich dachte mir
wir starten mal ein neues Format und
testen einen Tag lang nur das
schlechteste vom Schlechtesten und damit
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen Video
ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut ich
befinde mich hier gerade in der
deutschen Hauptstadt nämlich Bonn das
war natürlich nur Spaß wir befinden uns
heute in Berlin hier ist morgen ein
Youtube Event und ich dachte ich nutze
das ganze um mein neues Format zu
starten ihr kennt ja sicherlich noch von
früher als ich mal die schlechtesten
Restaurants getestet habe das
schlechteste Essen bestellt habe und so
weiter und so fort und ich dachte mir
wir machen das ein bisschen zeitgemäß
cooler ich werde einen Tag bzw einen
Abend erst das schlechteste Restaurant
testen dann die schlechteste Bar dann
den schlechtesten Club und überall
schauen also irgendwie so Sachen die man
halt abends machen kann um sich so am
Abend zu gestalten das natürlich
teilweise an der Cover alles mit dem
Handy mitgenommen und dann schauen ist
es dort wirklich so schlecht was es
vielleicht doch besser ihr versteht
wahrscheinlich nur in Berlin macht
sondern auch noch ein ganz ganz vielen
anderen Städten und auch natürlich
interessant wenn ich mal wieder weiß ich
würde sagen Wir labern gar nicht lange
und machen uns direkt mal auf den Weg
zum ersten Restaurant vorstelle ich euch
aber noch ganz kurz den Sponsor des
heutigen Videos vor und das ist
matchmasters dass ich aktuell ziemlich
suchte und Felix ist mal kurz mein
Gegenspieler
was machst du da eigentlich ich spiele
matchmas und du nee komm jetzt gib mir
mal mein Handy wieder Leute matchmasters
ist ein Handyspiel ihr könnt euch das im
AppStore und PlayStore einfach
downloaden und das geiles man kann gegen
Spieler auf der ganzen Welt spielen ihr
teilt euch einen Brettspiel und könnt
quasi mit einem Zug das ganze Spiel
gewinnen oder auch verlieren ist ein
Strategiespiel ihr müsst schlau sein und
mitdenken und ich ziehe jetzt mal kurz
Felix ab der matchmasse ist natürlich
auch auf seinem Handy hat
ich schicke dir mal Einladung ich
rasiere dich jetzt komplett weg so da
bist du schon man sieht halt dass du
absolute Anfänger bist
so pass auf ich bin dran ja was gefahren
weil ich bin eigentlich schon echt gut
so jetzt wünsche ich dir dann habe ich
nämlich zwei auf einmal
und ich schmeiße jetzt schon mal meine
Bombe
und jetzt geht's los mein Booster ja
weil ich hier die sieben von sieben
schon voll hatte
kurz zur Erklärung wie sich der Booster
auflädt in meinem Fall muss die blauen
Sterne sammeln ich brauche sieben Stück
davon und dann habe ich halt den Booster
voll und wenn man den Einsatz kommen
jetzt hier verschiedene Farben und man
sammelt alle Symbole auf einmal lohnt
sich also download euch matchmasters
über mein QR-Code oder über den Link und
ihr bekommt einen Pinata package
kostenlos viel Spaß beim zocken wenn ihr
besser sein wollt als Felix und
vielleicht fast so gut wie ich dann doch
recht Masters aus dem App Store oder
PlayStore erster Link in der
Videobeschreibung und wir gehen jetzt
los ich bin mal gespannt was ist hier
denn so richtig schlechtes gibt und was
ihr tanzen können okay Leute ich bin auf
jeden Fall jetzt draußen felix hat auch
einen anderen Termin der ist jetzt nicht
mehr dabei aber ich treffe mich mit zwei
anderen Freunden und dann geht's erstmal
los und das erste Restaurant leider ist
das Wetter jetzt ein bisschen schlechter
geworden in Berlin ich habe deswegen
auch ein Pulli an der Plan ist auf jeden
Fall dass wir jetzt erstmal ein
Restaurant gehen danach in eine Bar und
dann noch im Club alles super schlecht
Bewertung ich bin echt gespannt wie der
Abend verlaufen wird das Problem ist nur
Berlin ist so riesig es wird echt immer
eine Weile Strecke
die wir dann mit U-Bahn oder wie auch
immer fahren ich bin froh dass ich meine
beiden Freunde dabei habe die beide
Berliner sind also zumindest hier schon
lange Boden und ja auf dem hoffentlich
geilen und interessanten Abend mit nicht
allzu vielen schlechten Erfahrungen ich
bin einfach mal gespannt wobei gut das
mit keinen schlechten Erfahrungen wird
wohl und umgänglich sein na ja in Berlin
gibt es unfassbar viele Restaurants und
ich habe echt sehr sehr lange gesucht
bin dann aber auf das Restaurant R23
gestoßen was eine Bewertung von 3,2
Stern hat 341 Google Rezension insgesamt
dort gibt es Klassiker und
internationale Küche und viele Bewertung
sind halt ziemlich schlecht und man muss
halt auch wirklich sagen für ein
Restaurant wo es jetzt keine
massenabfertigen gibt sondern wo man
entspannt Speisen soll ist 3,2 schon
echt eine Ansage das Essen war
ungenießbar und der Kellner unfreundlich
gäbe es die Möglichkeit Nullstellen zu
vergeben würde ich es machen bodenlose
Frechheit wie man das Zeug was sie hier
machen verkaufen kann null Sterne geht
leider nicht aber dieser Schuppen wird
mich nie wieder sehen wir waren da und
der Kellner war sehr unfreundlich das
ganze Essen war total fertig zu dem hat
der Kellner bei bezahlen die EC-Karte zu
der hinteren Person geworfen nicht
schlechtes Essen super langweilig als
sie auf dem Weg zur Toilette an der
Küche vorbei kam roch es übel und das
sage Linde gesagt unhygienisch aus und
der Koch trug die schmutzigste Kleidung
groß Enttäuschung würde ich nicht
empfehlen ja das klingt doch alles
vielversprechend ich bin auf den Kellner
gespannt und wir gehen jetzt mal hin
Leute ich bin mittlerweile angekommen im
Restaurant jetzt befindet sich hinter
mir ich warte gerade noch meine beiden
Freunde und dann geht's rein ey er ist
der Sommer ist vorbei ne die Sonne ist
schon weg es regnet wir haben gerade mal
7:45 Uhr und es ist eigentlich schon
dunkel auf jeden Fall haben wir hier vor
uns das er 23
kaffeebare Restaurant mit echt vielen
sehr sehr schlechten Bewertungen und ich
muss sagen von außen sieht eigentlich
echt schön aus deswegen bin ich mal
gespannt ob es wirklich so schlecht ist
ich habe auf jeden Fall Hunger
mitgebracht und back to the roots wie
damals früher werden wieder ein paar
Restaurants getestet aber halt auch noch
andere Sachen bis gleich
also Leute kurz vorstellen das ist
wehtun langjähriger Freund von mir alles
fit und seine Freundin Didi hi auch wir
haben uns jetzt schon länger nicht mehr
gesehen aber ja wir gehen jetzt erstmal
das Restaurant testen es ist nicht gut
zumindest laut Google
Abend also ab geht's frei let's go okay
hier kann man einmal die Karte sehen
Hauptgericht ja klingt alles sehr
deutsch
eigentlich also der erste Eindruck ist
gar nicht so schlecht okay wir gehen
rein hoffentlich bekommen wir noch was
zu essen um die Zeit heute Weg danke
schön
ich wollte schon was trinken schauen wir
uns erstmal die Karte an der Dings das
wird italienisches Restaurant machen
oder viel mehr passt dazu solche
Gerichte der Kellner oder Chef hier ich
dachte doch gerade
ganz genau ich habe
nichts gesagt
Kopfschmerzen was zu laut ist oder keine
Ahnung naja egal ich glaube ich bin auf
jeden Fall schon mal eine Kartoffelsuppe
Berliner Art
Kartoffelsuppe
kann okay
ich mag ihn ich finde ihn auch nicht
aber wenn man es professionell sieht
oh das ist hier schmecken alkoholfrei ne
nie wieder wieso das Italien
noch mal nachgefragt ob es wirklich
alkoholfrei ist dann meinte der keiner
denkst du ich bin dumm und hat ihm jetzt
noch mal ein neues gegeben damit er sich
selber einchecken kann und überzeugt ist
ja ich verstehe das ich mache gar keinen
Sinn also
es gab schon mal ein bisschen Brot als
Vorspeise
ist auf jeden Fall sehr sauber und sieht
gepflegt aus vielleicht ist am Start
Papier ist am Start alles gut ich bin
aufs Essen gespannt
ist okay so meine Karottensuppe ist da
und die probiere ich jetzt mal
naja ich bin ja kein Koch mehr das muss
man sagen aber gut
[Musik]
oder
nein
Bauchschmerzen
aber ich bin mir nicht sicher aber die
Suppe schmeckt auf jeden Fall nicht
verkehrt mit der Vorgeschichte halt
jetzt nicht so einfach zu genießen ne
falls ihr das verstehen könnt
Komma fünf sieben sieben
auf jeden Fall das erste Restaurant ich
muss sagen ich habe jetzt auch wirklich
lange kein Restaurant mehr getestet und
versuche mich ein bisschen
zurückzuhalten das Essen war aber
grundlegend nicht verkehrt vor allem die
Suppe war lecker die Käsespätzle habe
ich jetzt nicht überzeugt und ich muss
auch sagen den Kellner konnte man
irgendwie so einschätzen auf der einen
Seite war nett auf der anderen Seite
auch ein bisschen weird und es gibt
sicherlich Kellner die besser mit Kunden
umgehen können was man zu sagen kann ne
man merkt das ein bisschen was da schief
läuft in dem Laden aber die 3,2 Sterne
finde ich ein bisschen zu geringer also
das Bier war eine 10 von 10 ja die Suppe
kann man machen
aber ich fand das Ambiente irgendwie so
ein bisschen wie in so einem falschen
Film
so in der Wüste im nirgend
dwo hi Leute drin die irgendein andere
Sprache sprechen der Typ komplett
verwirrt mal nett ich kann auf jeden
Fall verstehen was du meinst ja es ist
kein Restaurant wo alles richtig läuft
deswegen sind die Bewertung denke ich
online auch okay auch der Durchgang zu
den Toiletten wo man dann in der Küche
vorbei ging ist halt nicht optimal weil
die Küche sei jetzt nicht wirklich
hygienisch aus na ja aber wir gehen
jetzt weiter in die nächste Bar da
erwartet uns nämlich das nächste Blaue
Wunder ich bin gespannt ich habe glaube
ich alles schon gesagt konnte jetzt noch
eine Nacht mal drüber schlafen man muss
einfach ehrlicherweise sagen mit einem
entspannten schönen Abend wo man sich
wirklich wohl fühlen kann hatte das
jetzt nicht so viel zu tun trotzdem war
der Kellner irgendwo ganz nett hat uns
am Ende auch noch viel von seiner
Lebensgeschichte erzählt also ich glaube
er macht uns als gestern super war auf
jeden Fall okay hat mir geschmeckt auch
wenn ich immer noch nicht ganz so super
das eigentlich war aber ich glaube es
war die Kartoffelsuppe aber den Laden
müsste man auf jeden Fall mal deutlich
aufpimpen und ich kann nicht schlecht
Bewertung hier auf jeden Fall leider
nachvollziehen weiter auf unserer
Abendplanung stand dann die neue und
deshalb war in Berlin und die sticht mit
1.390 Google jeder zension und einer
Bewertung von 2,9 Sternen unter den Bars
auf jeden Fall deutlich hervor wir
schauen uns mal an was die Leute so
schreiben ich meine ich verstehe schon
das Konzert der einerskontrolle und so
aber die Frau die vor der Tür steht er
weckt den Eindruck dass die Irre ist
ihre Art der Umgang mit den Gästen und
der Kommunikation ist einfach nicht mehr
zeitgemäß empfehlen Sie diesen Ort auf
keinen Fall es sei denn sie mögen
schlechte Stimmung die Dame am Eingang
ist betrunken und benimmt sich komisch
die lächerlichste Tür Berlins der
Türsteher kommt anscheinend aus
besonders arm Verhältnissen und denkt er
sei was ganz Besonderes etwas habe ich
noch nicht erlebt diesen Laden muss man
aufgrund des Typ Personals boykottieren
spart euch den Weg und sucht bitte eine
andere Bar auf die haben wir noch eine
ziemlich lange Rezension die ich so ganz
amüsant fand zu lesen ich lese sie euch
jetzt nicht komplett vor deswegen stoppt
einfach das Video sonst geht's jetzt
weiter auch auf tripadvis ist die Bar
wirklich bodenlos Bewertung das meiste
bezieht sich wieder auf dem Türsteher
der Türsteher hat mich mit dem Hinweis
macht ich reingelassen ich weiß nicht ob
und was er sich reinzieht aber an seiner
Rhetorik und Methodik sollte dann auch
Arbeiten ich bin gespannt ich musste
ehrlicherweise sagen ich könnte mir
schon vorstellen was das für eine Bar
ist also die wollen so ganz exklusiv
sein wahrscheinlich aber ich bin noch
nie in meinem Leben egal ob am
Wochenende oder unter der Woche gestern
war unter der Woche in eine Bar nicht
reingekommen und wir schauen uns jetzt
mal an was in der neuen und deshalb war
so Leute hier sind war neue und deshalb
war sieht auch wieder eigentlich sehr
einladen aus und draußen zumindest gehen
wir mal rein
in Berlin ich habe dich doch jetzt nicht
Assi aus warum hat er zu mir auf
englisch
ist ja auch Donnerstag
also kann ich nur bestätigen ich bin
nicht reingekommen und ich glaube ich
kann mich an drei Sachen erinnern wo ich
in meinem Leben bis 40 reingekommen also
wirklich
Fußgänger testet wahrscheinlich wenn die
Drinks drin aber normal gewesen wie im
Internet auch stand bisschen teurer als
in anderen Bars ist halt so eine Party
halt auch so heiß Society macht ist
nicht ist und deswegen wahrscheinlich
auch so schlecht bewertet ist zu Recht
man ey und ich bin jetzt auch wirklich
sauer
einfach nicht reingekommen ich
vielleicht war mir einfach zu jung ich
hatte Hoodie an es ist eventuell so dass
man dort mit der sportlichen Kleidung
nicht reinkommt das akzeptiere ich ich
verstehe zwar nicht weil ich laufe
eigentlich so immer rum und ich hatte
noch nie Probleme man fühlte sich so ein
bisschen von oben herab behandelt das
kann ich auf jeden Fall nachvollziehen
deswegen machen die schlechten
Bewertungen hier auch leider irgendwo
sind keine Waffe für mich ich habe sie
leider nicht von innen gesehen hätte ich
gerne aber wir schauen mal was noch so
ging berlin ist eine Stadt die niemals
schläft du kannst eigentlich jeden Tag
abends feiern gehen egal ob Sonntag
Montag oder wann auch immer und so habe
ich mich auf die Suche nach einem
schlecht bewerteten Club gemacht der
aber eventuell auch nicht viele
Bewertung hat also irgendwie so ein
hinterzimmerladen ein große Clubs die
das ey du eight Berlin the pearl die
haben halt auch nur zwei Komma irgendwas
Sterne weil sich immer so viele Leute
beschweren dass sie dort nicht
reinkommen und dann halt eine schlechte
Bewertung hinterlassen ich war dort
schon teilweise und fand die Clubs
eigentlich ganz gut aber ich bin auf den
new West Club gestoßen der hat 41
Rezension und 3,5 Sterne und viele sagen
es ist überteuert es lohnt sich nicht
komisch um mal zu zitieren muss das weiß
nicht sehr unehregantes Ambiente meine
Freunde hatten von diesem Club auch noch
nie gehört und waren überrascht dass in
dieser Ecke überhaupt ein Club sein soll
deswegen haben wir uns auf den Weg
gemacht und ich war mal gespannt so als
nächstes kommen wir zum nächsten
Programmpunkt oder den schlechtes Gewürz
Club Berlin
[Musik]
geben die die macht auch richtig gute
Musik du hast jetzt welchen Song soll
ich Einblenden der läuft dann hier jetzt
Kabine wenn ich euch einchecken und
jetzt geht's los
[Musik]
okay Leute wir haben jetzt mittlerweile
11:30 Uhr und der letzte Stop auf meiner
Adresse was ich halt vorher recherchiert
habe ist der new West club in Berlin das
ist einer der schlecht bewertesten Clubs
der Club hat noch nicht viele Bewertung
und die sind aber größtenteils negativ
deswegen bin ich mal gespannt ob es da
wirklich so schlecht ist ich hoffe der
hat heute auf bei google steht ja es ist
Donnerstag in Berlin haben auch
eigentlich jeden Abend Clubs auf ne wir
werden mal sehen okay Leute wir sind da
aber nur Members Only soll ich mal
klopfen
ja ne
e
klingelt da ist doch Musik oder meinte
die können von drinnen da durch gucken
aber wir können halt nicht rein gucken
ich muss sagen die Preise sind ja alle
ganz normal so ist okay
dürfen wir dann da reingehen
Club am Wochenende bei unter der Woche
war okay Leute wir sind mittlerweile im
Club bzw Donnerstag ist das wohl eine
Bar aber wir sind die einzigen hier
obwohl der Alarm schon mit vier Stunden
auf hat und es ist natürlich alles super
dubios aber der Typ ist nett er hat uns
ein paar Getränk gezaubert die Karte ist
sehr vielfältig aber es gibt halt nicht
alles längst nicht alles trotzdem kann
es ja sein dass sie sich heute halt
dachten ja ist nichts los da brauchen
wir nicht viel investieren aber an sich
die Location okay also hier kann man auf
jeden Fall fette Sachen machen dann lass
uns noch mal krachen oder im Club
S
auf jeden Fall den relativ kurzer Zeit
an sehr dubiosen Locations ne was hast
du gesagt
schmeckt nicht besser nicht nehme
seit 20 Uhr
kommt nicht besser
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
lecker ist es keine Frage hey leute es
ist jetzt tatsächlich doch noch ein DJ
gekommen jetzt geht's hier los ich habe
gehört das extra eingeflogen
so wir sind mittlerweile auch wieder
raus aus dem Club das war doch ein
richtig schöner toller Abend mit vielen
schlechten Impressionen ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen und vielen Dank dass ihr
mitgemacht habt und so lange
durchgehalten habe es war ja auch
irgendwo ganz lustig und dann würde ich
sagen
und ich werde das auf jeden Fall auch
noch einen anderen Standort machen also
wenn es euch gefällt freue mich nach
oben und ja jetzt gehen wir mal um 1 Uhr
auch dann schon nach Hause 31 ja Leute
was soll ich sagen also an dem Tag was
halt irgendwie eine Bar und kein Club
der DJ kam ein bisschen verspätet für
zwei Bier ein Rum Cola und drei Berliner
Luft habe ich 28 € bezahlt was ich für
die Location ein bisschen teuer fand
aber so gerade eventuell noch im Rahmen
natürlich irgendwo eine dubiose Location
die auf mich den Eindruck machte als
würde man den Laden halt nutzen damit
der Betreiber dort mit Freunden
irgendwie abends mal einen trinken kann
also die kann sich irgendwie alle dort
so gefühlt die drin waren und wir waren
so abseits und ja waren halt Gäste
trotzdem waren alle nett und ich habe
mich überhaupt nicht unwohl gefühlt wie
ich erst gedacht hätte behalten nur
keinen Club das muss man sagen
kommentiert doch gerne mal in welcher
deutschen Stadt ich das noch machen soll
und an dieser Stelle auch noch mal
vielen Dank an matchmasters für sponsern
des Videos ihr könnt euch über diesen QR
Code Mensch was ist downloaden viel Spaß
beim Zocken Daumen nach oben da lassen
abonnieren für weitere Parts von dem
Format und ja Ursula ciao